good afternoon vincent we are now live
good afternoon
and welcome to the webinar series of the
ftth council europe
my name is vincent garnier i am director
general of the council
and i will be moderating this webinar
today's session is titled
an integrated approach to plan and
design
understanding a telecourse perspective
it is sponsored by science a member of
the ftth council
so
we will start with some words about our
organization
we are a non-for-profit association with
the mission to promote full fiber
network
as the most sustainable and future-proof
broadband technology
the council regroups 150 members
throughout europe
and among our key activity is the
organization of the annual ftth
conference
the next one taking place on march 29
and to 31st in vienna austria and you
will find more information about the
council and our activity on our website
this session is part of a series of
webinar we are organizing on a regular
basis to provide origins with insightful
content
from a leading industry expert
some practical information uh before we
effectively start
the session is recorded and a link to
the replay will be sent to all
registrant and participants after the
event
you are muted as an audience but you can
send us questions using the question
chat box we will do our best to address
them
with our panel in the second part of the
webinar
now
the past two years have proven
how essential good connectivity is in
our private lives
and for our economies
we have also witnessed an unprecedented
acceleration of fiber network rollout
throughout europe
we have now passed the 50
coverage threshold in europe
this is great news but it also means
that half of the continent is still to
be connected
many alternative operators are investing
in full fiber network while incumbents
are speeding up their development plans
with so much activity it is crucial to
pay attention to operations
yes we need to rule out fiber fast
but we should always do it with a higher
standard of quality
this fundamental infrastructure is there
for the next decade
we are doing this not necessarily only
for ourselves but more importantly for
our children for our children and for
the next generation
so this is why i believe today's
discussions are particularly relevant
our speakers will address emerging
trends on fiber rollout and the existing
design and development models
they will talk about alternative
methodologies technologies and tools for
effective network build-outs
and with a zoom on the situation on the
netherlands
we will also share some more holistic
consideration
important to a good understanding of
ftth rollout
so without further due let me introduce
you to our panelists
ladies first i will start with amrita
gangotra managing director
of
egypt digital solutions good afternoon
good afternoon
and then uh let me introduce you to
ariane 10 hover
he's ceo of volcker wessel's telecom
base in netherlands
good afternoon i am
good afternoon
and finally roid kumar who is head of
strategy and communication at science
our sponsor for today
and i will uh first ask
for ambita to
to walk us through
um
the first of a short presentation we
will have during the first part of the
presentation of the session
after which we will open for question do
not hesitate to ask the question in the
chat area we will address them with the
panel so amrita
the floor is used let me know when you
want me to to pass to the next slide yes
please thank you again vincent and good
afternoon to the audience good evening
and good morning
from europe
can you hear me
yes that's much better could you just
repeat from the start because we didn't
hear you for a second
okay
so uh thank you again uh vincent and
good afternoon to the audience in europe
and good evening uh in the asian
countries and in the u.s good morning
my name as you heard is amrita gangotra
and i'm learning my firm issue of
digital distribution
before that i held cpio and cio
positions in vodafone uk europe and in
part b airtel in india
ethos is a boutique consulting firm that
works with clients globally
both in developed markets and emerging
markets
it focuses on helping clients
enterprises oems and csps
with the network transformation agenda
required to make digital transformation
effective
it also works with technology product
companies with their go to market
strategy
with the evolving world uh
with the new technologies like 5g aiml
blockchain etc
so let's start with the obvious
statement that every enterprise today
especially after the covet pandemic has
hit the world
is focusing on digital transformation
that is digitizing their business
most organizations have pushed
the business operations to be more
online
have enabled employees to work from home
are building products and services that
are being consumed in the cloud using
latest technologies
now one of the most common element in
the success of the digital
transformation is connectivity
customers or employees
if they're using a service or product
that is being offered and their
experience is not good because of the
connectivity of the network that is
available to them the usage of that
of that product or services becomes
quite poor
so connectivity with good bandwidth and
low latency is something that
there is a huge demand for more and more
applications like gaming iptv etc
requires more bandwidth and lower
connectivity
now but for a very good connectivity the
need of the hour is fiber as you can see
in the slide over here when i compare
the fiber optics with
copper media
whether it is the bandwidth or whether
it's because you know you have more um
better
immunity to emi and rfi sustainability
whatever parameters you take the choice
is clear we have to move towards copper
now
when i look at copper
the word ftpx comes to the mind
but today i mean let's focus on um
let's look at the scph which is
fiber to the home
and if you look at some of the
statistics on the left
uh you know the communities that have or
they that enjoy over 46 better business
formation
as compared to some communities that
don't have fiber broadband services
when available rural markets enjoy
better average take rates 63 for fiber
broadband than urban
so there is a huge hunger in that sense
in the rural markets also
and communities with over 60 fph
availability have 64 better localized
gdp
you just heard from vinson also that in
europe
the fcph rollout is just about 60
so really speaking there is a lot of
demand and a lot of hunger for fiber as
to the home
but fiber roll out is not only to the
home so vincent if you go to the next
slide
let me explain the different elements of
fiber connectivity it's about
connectivity
uh and in the connectivity there are
different models where you're connecting
the central office
to different promises different
nodes so for example on the most
left-hand side you see fiber to the node
which is basically your connecting
universities or businesses or remote
places then uh you're aware of the huge
uh rollout of 5g that is being announced
4g has been rolled out
even
the wireless technology needs a lot of
fiber to backhaul the huge amount of
data that's getting generated into the
core of the network so you have cell
site fiber that is required so that's
fiber to the site and then of course
this fiber to the home
now when there are so many types of
fiber connectivity that is required
the network design process is very very
important
you when you start the whole process
there are a few steps that you have to
move through
the first one is the fundamental
planning part look at the existing
network
look at what you want to the as is and
the to be that you're transitioning to
and then create some manageable work
packages
after that you do need to look at the
outside plant evaluation needs to be
done the civil work identification of
the current passive network elements etc
then you get onto the back end the plan
and design
and that's mainly
in the office
that you sit and start doing the
planning and design the high level
design and the low level design which is
mapping the street design the street
information that you get the underground
cross-section views in-house
installation so from high level to
low-level design
and then you start the implementation
and once the implementation happens you
need to then go back and capture the
azure's build
and update the inventory database and
information in gis and other systems and
we'll go into the details of that uh
later on
now if you get to the next slide uh
vincent
um
there are a few critical success factors
for the rollout of fiber the sdta
of course i mean on technology side um
you know it's future proofing there's
maximum coverage that's there
the cost element is another factor when
you're rolling out fiber you will need
to look at
the capex and opex the workforce
productivity whether you're doing
greenfield or brownfield so the business
case it has to be developed business
case by business case and very pointed
areas have to be covered
once you have decided
how this rollout is going to happen the
project management and the slas and mean
time to repair all these things become
very very critical and then of course we
have to have the flexibility of the
rollout optimization of the truck rolls
etc so these are some parameters and
factors
that need to be continuously optimized
by csps or by any of the companies that
are rolling out fiverr they have to
collaborate with multiple
partners
in this rollout cycle
and due to multiple handovers and lack
of timely updates there are real
challenges as such there are new ways of
doing things that are new tools and the
the time here now is how do you do smart
scpx rollout
so let me hand it over to rohit and let
him explain a few of the things that can
be thought about in terms of tools and
techniques
thank you amrita
good morning good afternoon and good
evening to all the participants
depending on which
region you're joining us from
i lead the strategy function
here at science communications business
unit
science is a multinational company it's
a global company we
we work with 300 plus
enterprises communications is the
largest business unit wherein we serve
close to about 35
telcos around the globe
my primary responsibility here is to
draft the technology roadmap
um in line with the
market evolution and
accordingly work with the various
internal and external stakeholders
in order to make it a reality and that's
where
i work closely with amrita as well as
aryan on those friends
like i said we have been working
with csps
in certain cases serving them for more
than two decades
in terms of their network evolution and
network rollouts
and we have seen this uh this ecosystem
and this value chain emerge over the
years so initially it started off more
like a green field activity wherein the
demand was
still in its infancy and that's where
amrita spoke about
the process from
survey to plan and design to handing it
over to network operations and along the
way doing uh
[Music]
the rollout both in the last mile as
well as on the mid mines
but
the inherent challenge over there was
our inherent practice over there was
then built the network and the
subscribers would come that worked in
the initial phases because uh
the demand was still in its nascent
stages and the ecosystem was evolving
the the
network hunger uh the the
the bandwidth hunger was still in its
infancy
but now
you would have seen the kind of uh
network bandwidth demand that that has
happened in the especially uh post the
pandemic
error
in as per certain reports what we have
seen is from uh compared to early 2020
the demand has gone up close to about 25
or even more than that in certain
geographies clearly there is uh now an
enhanced need for the fiber to cater to
these uh
bandwidth needs the
the other technologies can best be only
adjunct to fiber but clearly fiber needs
to take center stage
and more more than that also the
uh the demand from the customers are all
the most sophisticated people are
demanding uh the services and uh
solutions
more precisely and more specifically in
terms of what they are looking for
so the initial traditional build-out
phase which was largely to
build it and then the consumers would
come in the subscribers would come in
now that has given way to what we call
as building for subscribers or build for
the demand
of of the consumers and in that sense
your end-to-end process yes the core
processes would remain the same but then
there is a need for all these processes
to talk to each other there's a need for
tighter coupling and integration between
all these processes and that's where
the technology plays a
greater role
essentially what we are talking about
here is
the
the the value chain needs to be
disrupted by bringing in automation and
analytics tools uh integrating that with
the geospatial technologies and all
these technologies have also evolved
over the years which which is now making
it all happen so when when we are really
talking about the digital transformation
of next gen networks there are three
aspects that we are talking about which
is primarily the the asset visibility in
near
real time at best and in certain cases
at real time on real-time basis the
second is the improving data quality and
i'm
intentionally mentioning here is
improving data quality and not an
improved data quality and i will touch
upon that point in the in the next slide
and obviously be reducing tco
uh vincent if you can go to the next
slide please
so essentially what we are talking uh
over here is uh data quality is of
utmost importance no matter what digital
transformation you run no matter what
automation and analytics integration you
want to do
data needs to be cleaned and what we
mean over here is that
the
data coming from one system should tally
with uh with that present in the other
systems the spatial data the attribute
data that needs to link itself properly
that needs to
uh
give a holistic picture only then we
will be able to save upon
uh the time the time that is currently
wasted in sort of a swivel chair kind of
an operation
and
the the automation would
would become a reality in the true sense
so
if we have to make the data quality
enhanced we need to have we need to
reduce the manual entry we need to have
rules and systems
which can take the data from the field
and then integrate that seamlessly back
to the gis system uh which which is
your
bible for for the entire attribute data
but
it it can't be a one-time exercise and
which is why i was mentioning in the
last slide that it is an improving data
quality it needs to happen on a
continuous basis it can't be done on a
one-time basis
it's a journey and that's where the data
governance plays a lot of
a big part in it which is why all the
organizations need to
come together and decide upon the roles
and responsibility of each individual
how would the data be passed on from one
system to the other there needs to be
accountability for each and every
stakeholder in that process
um and that's where uh if
if the data governance is set right
right from day one
that's where the data quality would be
maintained as a hygiene factor rather
than doing it as a one-time exercise
the next slide please
in all this
the the
second and most important element is the
role of geospatial software
and that plays a big part right from
planning
right until the
management and operations fit of it
that's the that's the place which is
also getting disrupted that technology
is evolving at a similar sort of a base
uh as any other technology
we are
increasingly seeing the use of lidar in
field visits
i think in europe uh based on certain
reports there is uh 24 cagr that we are
talking about from now until 2025 which
which means that a lot of manual surveys
will give way to lidar service and then
there are inherent advantages of going
through this uh lidar service uh right
wherein uh
the
the kind of precision that you can get
is as good as the manual service i
believe there was a
a test
or an experiment done in western
pennsylvania
wherein they actually compared the data
from a manual survey to a lidar survey
and the results were almost at par
the other advantage of lidar is it it
helps in terms of easy collaboration
because the data is already digitized
and then when you store it onto the
cloud a lot of these ecosystem players
can start collaborating on a real-time
basis
the second aspect which is
which is prominent is that the
cad and the gis portion
traditionally we have used cad software
primarily for the design aspect of it
but then the gis is more like a bible
for your for your records right um all
your attribute data all your spatial
data is stored on the
on the display and unless and until
there is a tighter integration of that
we will always have this kind of loose
ends uh lying around here and there
so
the integration between the two systems
the cad and the gis system is of utmost
importance and that's where
the
integration
would help in terms of faster planning
faster design
and then accordingly also in terms of
implementation and inventory management
to the next slide please which means
that
if if we look at this entire process
then
there possibly is a need to look at this
entire value chain more holistically
rather than at a point services basis
unless and until we look at this project
uh for this work holistically
our gains would only be limited from
that standpoint and that's where we
in in my uh view there is a need to
consider
the framework of managed fiber services
provider in same line as what we have as
managed network services provider in the
wireless world world
vincent back to you
well thank you very much for it and
before i hand over to aryan i just want
to remind to the audience that
please do not use a date to ask question
uh within 5-10 minutes we will move to
to the
pure conversation between the panelists
so uh use the question boss box ask your
question we will address them in a
moment
and now ayan the floor is yours
thank you vincennes
um
good good morning uh good evening every
participants in this uh meeting
and thank you
amarita that you give more the
architecture of fiber to the home
and rohit you said a lot about the
engineering
and typically you asked me to do some
introduction what we are as focal
vessels in the dutch market and what are
yeah
obvious main goals are in the fight to
the home markets so a short introduction
i'm ielts nova i'm ceo of fog versus
telecom and followed by telecom is one
of the
biggest uh
main contractors of the operators in the
dutch market for the fiber rollout but
also for other technologies we do a lot
of
copper technologies
mobile activities and you see here we
have five divisions in our company
for
all telecom activities that we have also
in germany
and next between that you see we have
some technical companies who especially
can help the fiber to the home business
and also the telecom business with the
goals or maybe the typical goals that we
have in holland
we have b main
you see the mavic sax it's a ground
penetrating radar
here it is an iot funnel and recognize
the software platform
so
this is focused telecom we do roll out
in holland for
many operators and also we have a very
strong corporation and relationship with
science
they invited us for this meeting
and
both we're looking also to the
engineering part of this because there's
a lot of
engineering things to do and we thank
you for your
very clear
talk about the engineering process i
think that we do a lot in this business
maybe next slide we can understand some
typical things
what we do what are our ftdx condition
and what's the dutch market because uh
vince had asked me especially for this
meeting can you tell me you know
specifically what is now in the dutch
market
one of the topics in the five rollout
and you see last year in holland we
connect seven hundred and thirty
thousand homes past and not homes
connected homes passed and we dig a
cable into the ground
and
i think so typically 190 200 of their
homes they are passed by focal vessels
telecom and that's our mark share that
we have and so
you can see that is a very
big amount if you look to the total
amount of numbers to connect
what is typically from that if you look
to the dutch market and what are the
challenges about that
is that what typically in the dutch
market is that the fight to the home
market is not protected by regulation
but it's regulations on the end customer
but not in roll out the infrastructure
so there are many participants in the
dutch market and sometimes private
equities and some pension funds they
invest to
to roll out the networks
or
some experience that we we roll out in
the past the most houses in the
period between 2007 and 2014 and after
that it stands stills
and two years ago we
we start up this engine again
and now we uh
achieve this amount of numbers and what
is typically for us in the dust market
that we dig the cables into the ground
and america that's shown as
shown before
that a typical
infrastructure who need this in the
fiber to the x market what we see in
holland especially
that is a very big
needed fiber roll out but we don't only
do it for fiber to the home
and so typically we build a network for
many operators and what is suspiciously
fiber to the home that is a fiber
rollout that is very big the growing
demand for digitalization in networks is
needed if you see in the covert pandemy
that people need
good connection they need goods they
have
fiber optics networks with no problems
and there's a lot of discussion about a
lower capex to
increase the speed of rollout of the
networks
and
and then in the next point what we see
is if you
make this huge amount of numbers
you pass a lot of infrastructure who's
already in the grounds and we see that
we we like to minimize also the damage
and that's especially one of the things
if you dig with this piece so many
kilometers in the dutch market you see
that we passed a lot of infrastructure
and sometimes it's not good on card it's
not good on engineering the data the gis
is not clear enough so it needs a lot of
innovation and that is what we do last
year we spent a lot of time in ground
penetrating radar so we can check if the
gis
was good enough is the network old
networks are good on the table and how
can we manage that by roll out a new
infrastructure or maybe sometimes we
roll out two five or two home
infrastructures in the same city
and it needs a lot of
i think organization
and designs
to do it very fast and without damage
maybe the next slide
but
we also look as we are a subcontractor
from the big operators like kpn vodafone
and some odf so one of the bigger one a
new
challenger in the dutch market and
t-mobile and if you look we also look to
our own goal that we have and i like
amira and let's say to us
like to go to see what is fiber to the x
well what we saw now we do a lot of
fiber to the home but if you look to our
goal and our goal is that we connect
everything to the fiber then we must
believe
maybe we must look to fiber to the x and
maybe we can connect everything and i
think if you connect
a lot of business cases to the same
network
then we can
improve the quality of life for the
citizens in the city
and what you now saw in the market and
also with from designing perspective
that we always do sometimes we design
networks two or three or five times
and if you look what is the best for the
humanity then we believe that our goal
is to connectivity and connect
everything on the fiber to the home
network and then from data we can use
the network
for a smart city
for a better quality of life and also
that this picture or present is one of
the pictures that we send in eindhoven
and there is an area that we connect
everything
and then you can see that
i think the technology can help us to
get a better life and also get a better
connection that's my topic for today
thank you
well thank you
very much i am um thank you alright
thank you thank you amrita i would like
now to to kick off the
who said the q a part of our uh our
conversation maybe starting with you
amrita you mentioned the importance of
data
i would like to reverse the question and
actually ask you
how does inaccurate data
or how would inaccurate data impact the
operation for a csp
thank you vincent uh you heard a lot
about the importance of data governance
from rohit
but let me explain uh you know what
happens if the data is inaccurate uh in
the various systems that the csp has
some missing or incomplete
you know connectivity information is
actually
quite a pertinent problem plaguing the
industry
it is not uncommon that csps
don't have correct information about the
data of about 15 to 20 percent of its
customers
and when the problem is left unattended
it just aggravates it just becomes
larger
not being able to identify accurately
the location of network fault when a
customer reports an outage
or being able to identify which
customers are affected by a failed
device directly impacts outage duration
and restoration
therefore an impact on customer
experience and customer satisfaction
so the telcos of the csps need to have
the highest quality of street level data
with robust access data sets
with ground cruise accuracy which is
less than even 10 centimeters
because you know keeping this accurate
and updated in the geospatial system is
fundamental
for the need for the
running operations and for the forward
rollout of the scpx while designing and
looking at the network
if you are uh having inaccurate gis data
it leads to delayed as uh and costly
network rollout also
the cycle just keeps increasing the
reliance on surveys and physical visits
increases quite substantially
and that could take 15 to 30 days of
provisioning and order fallout delays
of course there's the cost impact as
well on inaccurate inventory
and it leaves the stranded assets quite
unattended
actually i've had experience before also
where if we have got and governed the
data well or cleaned it up
you can re-harvest a lot of the data of
the assets that are lying there
and it could then reduce your cost also
there are other challenges like if there
is a redundant database because of mna
or different
gis systems when you do mergers and
acquisitions which is quite
common in europe as you would know
this leads to a lot of mismatches
and
therefore a lot of mismatches in
reporting even to the regulators or to
the management
so overall i would say the data
governance and the data cleansing is a
very important aspect
of this entire plan design engineering
and operations of scps
absolutely thank you very much and that
now maybe
i'm turning to to rorit
you you spoke and explain what critical
success factor of fttx deployment could
be but what are um in your view the
challenges uh to achieve success
in the attitude rollout
thank you vincent for the question um
like i was explaining
there is an inherent
design principle which has been followed
until now
there we normally the designers would
use the cad cam based system called cad
system in terms of doing the design
because the cad system offers a lot more
flexibility from that standpoint
but the record management is sitting in
your gis database and that's a more like
a database schema defined rules there
are constraints so obviously
one is one both of both the systems need
to be there but then one
system need to talk to each other and
then there is an overlay problem that
most of the
survey partners or or the construction
partners would carry paper based maps
onto the field and they would do the red
lines based on the construction that
they do or based on any management
activity that they go to so all these
three systems need to talk to each other
and
typically there is always a lag
the lag
would be if you don't use a
technology-based tools the lag could be
as much as uh one day to two days and
in certain cases there are missed
updates which amrita was also speaking
about there could be chances of manual
errors
while inputting the data and that means
that the as built data or has
versus the as planned data there is
always
some sort of a catch up or some sort of
a miss between the two and that is
something which which leads to
like i was explaining swivel chair
operation and uh increase in the design
time increase in the
uh uh build time and stuff
the other problem is uh when
when there are so many disparate systems
and some of them are even legacy systems
which the csbs don't want to touch
right
the real-time visibility of the data
end-to-end or of the network end-to-end
that is uh typically missing and that is
that hampers your speed of deployment on
one side
also in terms of uh
speed to restore or speed to even
identify the faults before restoration
those kind of uh delays are in in the
current day and
world could be detrimental to your
customer success
from your customers and that is
something that is a big challenge
that is there prevalent right now and
primarily if you if you look at the
end-to-end fiber roll-out process it's a
it's a cumbersome process it's it takes
a lot of time in some matrix was
suggesting that
every 16 hours
you need to connect thousand plus home
passes that number is going to become
all the more aggressive going forward
because of the enhanced needs from the
customer so you need to imbibe the
philosophy of automation and automation
is something where which has to be taken
in a bespoke manner depending on your
context because you can have some of the
systems talking
over mainframes mainframe based
technology some of the systems could be
talking to
uh your
system some of the systems would be
primarily gis based all these
technologies need to be looked at
holistically and then automation needs
to be planned
back to your institute thank you
um
i would like to to ask to to aryan and
maybe uh you know as a continuation of
where you left your presentation i noted
that you use the term fttx rather than
ftth and you you see
um i would say access network as one
unified uh network so could you maybe
elaborate a little bit and maybe um
give you give us your view on the
possible synergies between
um
mobile network backhaul transport 2
wireless antenna and increasingly 5g
and the ftth we are currently rolling
out both ftth
network and also preparing for the
development of 5g at the ftth council we
made some research to show that there is
a lot of gain in approaching both
investment in synergy i'm very
interested to get your view on that as
well
thank you vincent good question um and
our appointment on that is
um
maybe it's typical in holland but i
think it's global thing that there are
existence networks who deliver
some 4g
and sometimes a
copper network who needs connection for
for um for internet and what you saw is
that we typically design a lot of
networks
from the
the old network to the new network so he
built and a couple connection home
network to the fiber to the home
proposition and if you look to a rather
perspective and you look to a city and a
city needed fiber they also needed fiber
for 5g and you see that
that mobile and fixed networks are more
connected to one
uh
design and that's typically what rohit
said before about the geese if you look
to the gis networks you already exist
why did we build a network who connects
also
maybe land poles
street lighting and other optics if you
then you have more possibilities to roll
out
maybe a fine base network for 5g in the
in the future but what you saw is that
and what i saw in the discussion that we
started before that a lot of business
cases are based on capex and opex so
what you see is that we design a lot of
networks from one solution sometimes
private to the home but if you have a
global perspective and you look to
administrativity then you see that
there's a lot more connection but
sometimes the business cases are not in
the same time same area and same
infrastructure so i think if you design
more for a higher perspective you must
sometimes have spare in your network to
do the fiber rollout maybe provided to
the site and you can connect
a note from 5g on the on the on the on
the 5 to the home network
so if you look so to architecture
yeah the only
dimension rule that we have on fiber to
the home is the speed of light
so you can connect everything
and
but you have to
be aware that your business case is not
only five to the home and i think that's
one of the challenges for the operators
business cases for today is not a
business case for tomorrow and
that is one of the topics that we said
that we call it five to the x i think
now we do five to the roll out in
holland for a lot
but i think the next phase is to make
smart cities and make five to the x
sometimes we have to design
more 5 to the x and from that plastic
back to 5 to the home that's another way
of thinking
very interesting thank you very much
and amrita i think you you just
mentioned copper and uh i would like to
ask you a question related to
copper switch-off we see in some
european country and we see some
operators starting to develop plan for
phasing out copper
it's not necessarily an easy process
and so how should the copper switch off
and the fiber rollout program
effectively be managed and what is your
view on
some of the major challenges to be
cognizant of
yeah vincent i mean uh it's easier said
than done these are mega projects
multi-year projects
and a lot of stakeholders
are involved in this the vendor
ecosystem is also very large
and then customers the end customers are
involved
so uh if i look at the challenges i
would really bucketize them in three
areas the first and foremost are the
regulatory concerns or the constraints i
would say
so uh you know in some of the markets
you have this uh
obligation the universal access fixed
service
obligation that has to be there which is
based on the copper network and you know
transitioning through that there are
wholesale providers that the incumbent
has to cater to and if the wholesale
customers have also co-invested then if
there's a mismatch
then it is very hard to
you know
follow the obligations that are there as
far as regulations are concerned
the second thing in regulations i would
say that you know you have to have the
local municipality
[Music]
approvals and that is quite a challenge
you need the buy-in and you need the
right-of-way permissions it takes a long
time the necessary permissions to switch
off switch on dig all of that is quite a
big
challenge as such
the second challenge i would say is
mainly the organizational challenge
now when you're executing such a large
program multi-year program
across the country across different
locations nationally coordinating with
internal and external um you know
stakeholders communication
it is uh you know quite challenging um
you know while there are a lot of
synergies in the copper switch off with
the fiber rollout it requires a very
defined transformation structure to be
put in place for the duration of the
execution it's not uncommon for
operators to hire temporary specialist
staff to handle this transformation
and thirdly but not the least it's the
customer wise migration issues that we
face
you know migration migrating each and
every customer from the legacy network
to the new network is an enormous
planning communication and logistic
hurdles there are high risks of customer
churn but at the same time there is an
opportunity to upsell higher value
products to the customer
managing the public image is another
thing that uh is very relevant and uh
you know quite challenging sometimes
but as one of the nordic
telephone cto once said that it is not
about the 300 000 homes that were
successfully migrated during the
switch-off that determined the success
of the migration it was also the
handling of the public relationships
the public relations and the fallout
that might have occurred with the homes
that had problems during the migration
the company sought active engagement
with relevant stakeholders customers
and mitigated the negative articles in
the press
so all in all you know while there is a
wow factor uh for moving and upgrading
the product it is a challenging and mega
transformational project really
simpson
thank you
uh maybe back to you right you
i i noted from from your presentation
that you were talking about manage fiber
service provider
um
as an important point uh
is there anything you want to to
elaborate on uh
concerning this specific topic
sure
actually i am taking the leap out of the
equivalent practice currency which is
primarily in the oem space
and for wireless rollouts wherein the
csvs hand over the entire network
management deployment and management to
the oems
and these are mega projects and then
the csps would monitor it
and
and that's where it's the managed
network services uh
play over there
if you look at the final
process
[Music]
the fact that there are so many
disparate elements so many disparate
systems
all the entire process needs to be
looked at holistically rather than on a
piecemeal basis oftentimes if we address
try to address the problem on a
piecemeal basis the results will also be
in the similar light
and hence there is a need to look at the
entire process entire value chain more
holistically so starting with what
amrita mentioned about the copper switch
off program that is a is a
complete
uh implement process that needs to be
looked at
and apart from that there needs to be a
phase-out plan as well
because there is a there needs to be an
overlap between your copper network and
your fiber network there is a uh there
is an optics
cost which you will be incurring as a
service provider if you keep both the
networks running
but
[Music]
the second aspect is uh
especially in the urban and semi-urban
area the congested areas
not every time fiber feasibility would
be would be
possible and possible
now
what do you do in that kind of a context
because fiber is something which which
is the only
media that is only alternative that is
there right now which can cater to the
bandwidth demands right
there needs to be a aggregation of
technologies there needs to be a
mix of technology which has to be rolled
out can we look at
fwa can we look at migration to an ip
kind of an infrastructure wherein the
need of fiber rollout is reduced from
that perspective and that's something
which
if you look at the program holistically
and only then you will be able to
decipher the third aspect is primarily
from um
what's happening currently in europe
there is a lot of uh
initiatives running wherein people want
to ride over a shared infrastructure
now if you need to
do an effective planning of your entire
network
you need to have an integrated system
with a wholesale provider as well as
from a csp perspective in terms of
understanding where those ducks are
there which which are shareable where
where are those
what is that shared infrastructure which
can be leveraged and basis that you can
create an effective design which will
work both both in terms of
technology or the cost as well as from a
time perspective and that is something
which is which needs to be also looked
at
if you only look at
plan and design process in in isolation
or survey process in isolation you're
never going to get a holistic view of
things and that's where the efficiency
would only be there on a piecemeal basis
from that perspective okay
very clear
thank you
um i noted you you're also active in
germany
and germany is by far the largest
potential in terms of
fiber rollout for for the years to come
there are there are many many households
to still to be connected and it's a huge
country
um
is there any any takeaway you have from
your experience of the german market and
maybe share what are the challenges
you're facing there
now
if you as a as a dutch company go to
germany you think also
also that people like
they have the the clear
view about that market but if you look
to the german market it looks especially
to the five to the home you see there's
a
huge country with a lot of numbers to
connect
but typically you saw that
the infrastructure is
really
region based and also the operator
operator region based and also the rules
to dig cables into the ground and the
local municipalities
make the
the lands more complex
than then we look to holland and what is
uh we have more
uh regulated rules uh for digging and
also roll out fiber networks so that's
one of the thing the second is
that the infrastructure is less if you
look to the big cities there's a lot of
infrastructure but if you look to the
rural area between the big cities
there is
not an existing network like
copper or coax so you need to invest
a huge amount of meters digging cables
into the ground before you
you arrange the city to to roll out
fiber so that's one other thing and
second one of the thing is that the
capacity to roll out
the works the work squad you needed now
it's it's a new market for there so if
the amount is high
and
there are not a lot of technical people
to do that
and they're already working in the
infrastructure with copper or otherwise
so you have to think
um otherwise to to
to this challenge is that over there and
if you look to the designer
perspective there are a lot of cars not
available so that we
we drive in a lot of cities with cars
like the google cars and we make
pictures
of uh of houses and also pictures of
pavements and pictures of
things so we can design a network so we
make new cards over there to design a
network and that's one of the challenges
so i think
your question is very clear if you look
the market is very big so you can use
your experience from holland and bring
them to germany to have a very good
business case but you must
think like a german and then you can
locally
base your capacity and then you can
start with the fiber roll out so it's
very complex to do that
and if you look to the mobile
perspective and you combine those things
yeah i think
if you you you you go to your question
you had before can you combine
mobile activities and fiber activities i
think that is needed in germany to
combine
both things because there is a lot of
need for mobile activities but also to
connect the mobile
lan post to the 5 to the x network
so there's a lot of challengers
but i think the capacity
and also
the need of what they have in germany
it's very it's a very good market to
stay on that and
and and make a lot of
new networks over there
yeah i guess you're right every every
country in europe has a specificity you
can't you just copy paste and imagine
that it will work similarly well but all
country are faced with that question of
um maybe lack of of skill labor to
to be able to
indeed
roll out as fast as uh i would say the
plan would uh
with hope um yeah and what you saw is
that you you're directly in in
direct contact with that challenge as
well
what you see is that
there are a lot of countries who needed
a lot of amount of numbers of fiber and
if you look to
regulation but also in traineeship how
to train the labor
companies and and how to manage the
labor costs and that's one of the thing
and and i think um yeah
it's like some kind of work around who
goes between europe and from holland and
germany now to belgium
there's a lot of fiber needs so we also
have to arrange a work squash who can
make these challenges available princess
okay
and i'll take that as your conclusion if
you mind don't mind iron and and use the
the the remaining uh
three four minutes we have in our
session maybe to ask uh amina to
to to
to share your your conclusion uh
about this session about any
consideration you would like to uh to
express to the audience today
can you ask me
yeah yeah sorry i was asking you we are
close to the end of the session so if
there is a few words you would like to
to say to conclude your contribution
yes
yeah thanks ervinson as we were just
discussing why you know we've seen that
fiber
is very much required
there is the hunger and need for more
bandwidth the fiber is absolutely
critical
but
given the various challenges we
discussed um also the labor shortage
actually and the labor training that
needs to be done which you touched upon
in the end
uh and the data integrity uh there there
has to be a focus and a manner in which
we can uh program manage it well number
one number two a lot of automation and a
lot of uh
process uh
automation
uh there has to be
a way to do this more smartly which
rohit was talking about you know the
tools and other aspects so considering
all of that
challenging times ahead but very much
required i think most of the uh you know
csps and other companies in europe
will gain from this rollout that is
required
well thank you very much and maybe
turning to you roid for the final world
um
what are your
key takeaway from uh from this
discussion of today
um i actually
quite enjoyed this session especially
the perspective
uh for from the various uh markets uh
which aryan uh mentioned uh specifically
from a netherlands and germany
perspective and how
the various technologies are getting
used what is what is the on ground
challenges from that standpoint and
amrita's perspective on best practices
to be adopted actually um i would
i think
there is a there is a need for us to
relook at that entire value chain and
evaluate how how
how and what kind of optimization and
efficiency gains can be had from that
entire process
where are those bottlenecks and unless
and until we have a visibility of that
entire value chain where are those
congestion points where are those
bottlenecks we will not be able to fix
them and that requires tighter
integration between the systems fighter
integration both from on field as well
as desktop-based
crew
and
looking at it more holistically than
what it is
then what's happening right now
well thank you very much um
so many questions still to address um
and i see a lot of
opportunity to bring
smart solution to help
all european countries develop better
and faster
ftth until we have a holistic
coverage uh
connecting everything everywhere i am to
to build that
general communication network you you
think and you explain is so essential
for for the future of our
of europe and and the communities in
europe
so i guess we also you didn't really
touch about it but the question of
sustainability is also everywhere uh
underlined in in everything you you say
that is also essential uh to to take
into account in the rollout and
those networks will be also instrumental
to to be able to to to take up the the
challenges of climate change
so i would like to uh to thank uh
the panelists thank our audience
and uh wish you a good rest of your day
stay tuned more webinar session will
come in in the weeks
ahead of us
so
we'll have the opportunity to talk again
and share with you a very insightful
contribution from our experts thank you
very much
thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you goodbye
you